¿Cuál es la intersección
entre la tecnología, el arte y la ciencia?
La curiosidad y la maravilla,
porque nos impulsan a explorar,
porque estamos rodeados de cosas que no podemos ver.
Y me gusta usar la película
para que nos lleve en una travesía
a través de los portales del tiempo y del espacio,
para hacer lo invisible visible
porque lo que hace
expande nuestros horizontes,
transforma nuestra percepción,
abre nuestras mentes
y toca nuestro corazón.
Aquí tenemos unas escenas
de mi película IMAX 3D,
"Los misterios del mundo desconocido".
(Música)
Hay un movimiento bastante lento
para que lo detecten nuestros ojos,
y el lapso de tiempo que nos permite descubrir
y ampliemos nuestra perspectiva de la vida.
Podemos ver cómo los organismos emergen y crecen,
cómo una vid sobrevive trepando por los árboles
para ver la luz del sol.
Y a una gran escala,
el lapso de tiempo nos permite ver nuestro planeta en movimiento.
No solo podemos ver la vasta extensión de la naturaleza
sino el movimiento agitado de la humanidad.
Cada línea marcada con un punto representa un avión con pasajeros,
y al convertir la información del tráfico aéreo
en una imagen de lapso,
podemos ver algo que constantemente está arriba de nosotros
pero es invisible:
la extensa red de tráfico aéreo por todos los Estados Unidos.
Lo mismo podemos hacer con los barcos en el mar.
Podemos convertir la información en una vista del lapso de tiempo
de una economía global en movimiento.
Décadas de información
nos permiten tener una vista completa de nuestro planeta
como un único organismo
sostenido por las corrientes que circulan por todos los océanos
y por las nubes que giran por la atmósfera,
latiendo con los relámpagos,
coronado por la aurora boreal.
Pudiera ser la última imagen del lapso del tiempo:
la anatomía de la Tierra traída a la vida.
Al otro extremo
hay cosas que se mueven muy rápido ante nuestros ojos,
pero contamos con la tecnología que puede ver ese mundo
también.
Con cámaras de alta velocidad,
podemos hacer lo contrario que sucede con el lapso del tiempo.
Podemos filmar imágenes que son mil veces
más rápidas que nuestra visión.
Y podemos ver cómo funcionan los ingeniosos dispositivos de la naturaleza
y quizá aún podemos imitarlos.
Cuando una libélula revolotea,
puede ser que no se den cuenta,
pero es la mejor voladora de la naturaleza.
Puede flotar en el aire, volar hacia atrás,
incluso boca abajo.
Y al rastrear los marcadores en las alas de los insectos,
podemos visualizar el flujo de aire que producen.
Nadie sabía el secreto,
pero la alta velocidad muestra que una libélula
puede mover las cuatro alas en direcciones diferentes
al mismo tiempo.
Y lo que aprendamos nos puede llevar a
clases nuevas de voladores robóticos
que pueden expandir nuestra visión
sobre lugares importantes y remotos.
Somos gigantes, y no estamos conscientes
de las cosas que son muy pequeñas para que nosotros las veamos.
El microscopio de electrones dispara electrones
que crean imágenes
que pueden magnificar cosas tantas veces
como un millón de veces.
Este es el huevo de una mariposa.
Y hay criaturas ocultas viviendo por todo nuestro cuerpo,
incluyendo a los ácaros que pasan toda su vida
viviendo en sus pestañas,
gateando por su piel durante la noche.
¿Pueden adivinar qué es esto?
Piel de tiburón.
Una boca de una oruga.
El ojo de una mosca de la fruta.
Una cáscara de huevo.
Una pulga.
La lengua de un caracol.
Pensamos que conocemos la mayoría del reino animal,
pero puede ser que haya millones de especies pequeñas
esperando ser descubiertas.
La araña también tiene grandes secretos
porque el hilo de seda de la araña es gramo a gramo
más fuerte que el acero,
pero completamente elástico.
Esta travesía nos llevará hasta
el mundo nano.
La seda es 100 veces más delgada
que el cabello humano.
En ella hay bacterias,
y cerca de esas bacterias,
10 veces más pequeño, hay un virus.
Dentro, y 10 veces más pequeño,
hay tres hebras de ADN,
y cerca del límite de nuestros microscopios más poderosos,
hay átomos individuales de carbono.
Con la punta de un microscopio poderoso
podemos mover átomos
y empezar a crear asombrosos dispositivos nano.
Un día algunos podrán patrullar nuestro cuerpo
para cualquier tipo de enfermedad
y limpiar arterias obstruidas en el camino.
Las pequeñas máquinas químicas del futuro
tal vez un día podrán reparar el ADN.
Estamos a la puerta de avances extraordinarios,
los cuales surgen de nuestro impulso
para descubrir los misterios de la vida.
Así que bajo la lluvia interminable del polvo cósmico
el aire está lleno de polen,
micro-diamantes y joyas provenientes de otros planetas,
y explosiones supernova.
La gente lleva sus vidas
rodeadas de lo invisible.
Sabiendo que hay tanto a nuestro alrededor
que podemos ver
que esto cambia por siempre nuestro entendimiento del mundo
y al ver los mundos invisibles, reconocemos
que existimos en el universo viviente,
y esta nueva perspectiva crea maravillas
y nos inspira a convertirnos en exploradores
en nuestros propios jardines.
Quién sabe lo que espera ser visto
y qué nuevas maravillas transformarán nuestras vidas.
Únicamente tenemos que ver.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.